[Music]  the rumors still haven't gone away I've  learned more about humiliation in the  past few weeks and I hoped I would in a  lifetime you married a wild spirit  trying to tame them is news  I've been queen barely ten years and in  that time I've had three Prime  Minister's not one has lasted the course  I understand the Prime Minister's  resignation it's not just the Prime  Minister and your mother and your sister  and country the whole relentlessness of  it all the fact it never stopped stop  for a minute  but is it not possible that ammo all  those problems there are some of us who  were there for you no matter what if  only  [Music]